okay on to the next game
the grateful dead um
i played him already a couple of times
let's vary with
some quiet instead of the queen's gambit
it's not without its points
oh it chooses to
to play quietly i could also play c4 now
go back to the queen's gambit
but
i stay within the queen's pawn
territory
yeah seems he wants to play bishop a6
here
to exchange my bishop on d3
i like to prevent that for at least a
move
yeah of course he's got
knight to e4 okay
just develop in a sensible fashion and
see later what what might be an idea
here okay
this is surprising
interesting i'm not sure
how i should take here
so
so what next go e4
let's looks um
sensible but
not very ambitious i
try something else i try to go f4 knight
f3 and then
try to get some attack going here
it's maybe a little bit risky oh
he just um wants to play knight e4 again
yeah okay if he goes 94 i just
take with the knight and retreat the
bishop and then maybe go
f3
another idea i could have thought about
was bishop h4
in order to exchange the bishop in case
he moves the night
this looks um also like a good idea
yeah i take it now
and now bishop c2
another idea actually could be to
try to attack this pawn with queen g4 at
some point
but then he most likely would play
simply f5
yeah it's playing sensible moves
maybe also bishop b3 in order to go for
d5
this could also be an idea
yeah i like this idea
opening up the d file
uh-huh so trying to
go h5 or something
maybe
maybe d5 isn't a good idea after all
not sure
but okay let's let's try take it
then d5 you could go e5 of course
then maybe bishop a4 to c6
yeah he will he will have something with
with f5
later i try that
taking on d5 of course should be okay
for me because i will always get this
pawn back
at some point
yeah you should go e5 maybe this is
really good for black f5 to come
yeah i guess this wasn't a good idea
well let's see maybe he doesn't he
doesn't take he doesn't play e5
it's certainly the best move
yeah now bishop a4 otherwise this
doesn't make any sense at all
okay and now i
just i just need to play this here
to to
clarify this situation here okay it's a
pawn but
i'll always have play against them
against d6 and against the queen side
if i play slowly he just goes f5 and so
on
so now i attack d6 and e4
i think i'll get one pawn back now
i'm not sure i think it wasn't it wasn't
easy for him at all to
to keep the material
so what now can can i take take on e5
takes e5 de rook d8 queen d8 queen c6
this is a pawn right
on rook c4 i got re7 i think
yeah you will get some counter play of
course queen d1 to come
at the end of this line
but still i think i have to go for this
hmm interesting what's what is he
thinking about
check
yeah now these two pawns are hanging
maybe queen e4
so now i could give the check here
or something else f4 maybe
to get here
check
oh this is almost checkmate
queen f8 and now g4 would be made if
possible
okay
can i do some
something here
oh no i blundered f4 check
check check
check check
check black forefits on time
okay just the time when
this looked really dangerous let's check
quickly with the computer
oh i got a mate i got a mate queen of
eight shack
king h5 queen g7
and then ah this is easy actually
h7 is hanging and he needs to play h6
queen e5 g5 queen e8 check
yeah this end up in the mate i should
have seen this
now okay but at the end
the time helped me for once